et luc ferrandez est avec nous sur le
plateau le souffle à rodez bonsoir
démission de tous là vous en allez
maintenant demain c'est terminé elsa
komori bon vous dit
j'avais le sentiment de berner les gens
en restant dans cette administration là
parce qu'on fait pas ce qu'il faut faire
en environnement oui mais il faut avouer
que ce que je propose de faire un
environnement c'est un truc aussi pour
jamais se faire élire donc je suis
conscient le que la mairesse veut pas
tout prendre donc déjà une station en
place c'est la meilleure illustration
romaine en matière de lutte contre les
effets de serre et environnement des
dernières années c'est la façon la plus
progressiste depuis jean doré mais
l'homme est un moment d'urgence
je pense que la plupart des gens
comprennent pas le 2° à 2005 le giec qui
amy qui a accepté de dire que si on a
les adieux de grillons ce n'est des vers
une catastrophe aurait révisé son
jugement récemment en disant c'est un
point cinq degrés si on dépasse 1.5
degrés ça va aller très mal et là on est
en 1.312 grille de différentes donc
juste là le actuellement la le prix des
aliments augmentent en flèche parce que
on a 12 à 20% d'agriculture qui s'est
effondré aux états unis et puis tu as
plusieurs pays
on le voit avec on le voit avec les
inondations etc ça c'est un point des
grilles à 1.5 degrés on est à 40 %
disparition de l'agriculture
il faut agir maintenant il faut agir
fort il vous voyez pas assez des
décisions dans votre administration que
vous jugez contraire à ses intérêts la
tv par exemple on m'a derniers mois dit
vrai nom par exemple on a on va prendre
des décisions sur des projets de
construction de piscine à 50 millions de
maisons de la culture à 80 millions de
nouveaux boulevards à 200 300 millions
de dollars
moi je pense qu'il faut concentrer tout
l'argent tout de suite dans l'achat du
terrain naturel dans tout ce qui reste
vert dans l'achat de terrains en rive
il faut concentrer notre référent
pendant les dix prochaines années sur la
crise environnementale en fait toutes
les dessine en vironnement de repos j'ai
fait un enjeu
ça devrait l'enjeu qui le quai le filtre
de l'ensemble de nos décisions comme
vous dites par exemple un construire un
deuxième stade de baseball à montréal
générés
une grossesse à dire que ça c'est en
terme de discours en termes de discours
madame plantes que je respecte
à chaque fois il faut prononcer son nom
je t'aime en appelant que je n'espère
d'accord parce que courageuse et
travaillante mais elle essaie de l essai
de répondre à tous les montréalais et
dans cet effort loi veut pas dénoncer
comme moi je le ferai
le consumérisme et le consumérisme
ultime le consumérisme ultime la
consommation ultime c'est de se doter
d'un deuxième stade quand on a déjà un
premier un deuxième stade qui va être
financée entièrement par les immeubles
qui vont entourer donc la spéculation
immobilière et il s'en priver en
coulisse vous faisiez ces batailles vous
doucement
c'est de la folie de la marque est ce
qu'on vous dit qu'on n'était pas
d'accord on puisse s est intéressant
composé cette question est là parce que
notre désaccord ne s'est jamais traduit
par des espèces de bataille de crêpage
de chignon qu'on imagine parfois c'est
le journal de montréal sans cesse dit
par exemple luc ferrals elle se fait
taper sur les doigts ou les des mots
trop durs la mairesse nantais vous a dit
c'est moi le patron ça oui c'est vrai
dans l'immédiat elle est obligé de
rectifier de dire c'est moi le patron
c'est moi la mairesse
on se met à sa place c'est la première
mairesse de montréal puis moi j'étais
l'ex-chef alors mais vous disiez qu'en
coulisse voient leurs fesses gc bataille
là et vous vous dites vous les perdez
une appréciation après l'autre parce que
au comité exécutif
on en est pas à ce niveau niveau de
conscience moi je pense nécessaire pour
faire face à la crise environnement et
quand vous dites nous votre conscience
lors on va voir un tableau vous vous
dites qu'une révolution fait que vous
avez fait sur le plateau c'est la petite
bière vous dites pour taxer 100% du
stationnement sur rue et aux rues taxes
et l'entrée au centre ville donc des
péages urbains comme à londres
taxer les déchets ça s'est déjà fait
taxer la viande empêcher
l'agrandissement de l'aéroport acquérir
et jolie tous les terrains vers vous en
avez parlé encore disponibles réinventer
le recyclage et cetera planter 500 mes
larmes alors ma question référendaire
là vous sortez vous allez avoir beaucoup
moins d'influx ans à l'extérieur qu'à
l'intérieur
bon d'abord les flancs ce que j'avais à
exercer l'ensemble des prochains que
j'ai lancé
grand parc de l'ouest au grand parc de
l'aize les corridors verts les trois
nouveaux grands pas et c'est je les fais
les travaux sur ses parts soit terminée
pas terminé mais c'est dans la machine
c'est à dire que maintenant ce sont des
fonctionnaires travaillent dessus et la
place mais guy la rue sainte-catherine
la plaie car et philippe lapeyrie
montréalaise et c'est alors la menace
que ce travail-là de base et féminin
aura fallu pousser plus loin puis pour
pousser plus loin
je sens que je sens que projet montréal
a besoin d'un choc besoin de faire dire
par ses membres
allons plus loin et il ne gérons pas ne
gérons pas
de façon standard de façon classique
d'un politique montréalaise
on n'est pas dans un moment de son
standard de la halle de la mairie se
troue pactiser avec les intérêts
économiques qui à votre avis fait qu' il
ya trop de compromis oui vous avez lu
dans mon texte par exemple que je
m'empresse de dire que de l'acier plus
représentatif que moi et que moi
j'aurais jamais été élu avec un
programme comme celle là c'est elle qui
a été élue si elle qui a faim à prendre
la décision de comment va poursuivre sa
route à travers une gauche qui pousse
une droite qui poussent mais moi je
m'arrange pour pousser par exemple je
sors la politique pour pousser pour dire
ben voilà mais quel intérêt pour nous
poser la même question à nicolas hulot
qui a claqué la porte du gouvernement
français quel pouvoir puisqu'elle quelle
prise aurez-vous emprise aurez-vous sur
l'édition puisque vous serez plus là
jamais mais quand je suis là je donne
une sans caution une caution et que je
ne veux plus donné et ça c'est j'imagine
comme nicolas hulot c'est peut-être un
exemple des trop grandes pointures pour
moi mais je ne serai prêt tout le maire
d'arrondissement
mais hélas nous faire et ak vous dit
[Rires]
peut-être le plus connu des maires
d'arrondissement auront peu moins
d'espoir l'humilité qui vous étouffe
non non non écouter ça prend un peu de
dégoût là pour faire le travail qu'on
fait des conflits
donc j'ai perdu ma phase où dit je ne
veux pas être la caution
oui c'est ça de madame plantes la
question environnementale
comment est ce que je suis oui
absolument
l'ati la médecine mais reste par des
décisions dans son bureau avec son
cabinet puis mais ce n est pas juste
monsieur vélo il y en a à travers le
monde en ce moment les discussions au
sein du parti démocrate monsieur biden
devait se présenter à la présidence a
fait beaucoup attaqué par le parti
démocrate pour dit on veut un plan
environnemental plus radical que ça
alors justement la suite parce que vous
êtes préoccupé par comme beaucoup de
gens on a vu ces jeunes qui marchait qui
marche de plus en plus pour
l'environnement
vous allez faire quoi qu'est ce qui va
être plus productif
c'est pas ce que je vais faire que va
être plus productifs c'est ce que le
cabinet va faire c'est ce que le cabinet
la mairesse vont faire suite à cette
pression que je fais aujourd'hui que je
continue de faire en dix ans il ya une
partie des électeurs qui considère que
vous allez pas assez loin et c'est la
seule pression qui peut faire bouger les
choses parce que c'est cette pression là
qui contrebalance la pression de droite
donc vous allez toujours là vous allez
prendre la parole vous allez donner des
entrevues
oui jalila j'allais à suivre à la trace
venez de venir se sont couverts de l'ue
en cauchemar
non non je suis pas du style quand je
parle mais je suis persévérant
puis je compréhensif aussi je sais c'est
quoi la difficulté de faire avancer une
ville prend des décisions mais je suis
persévérant
donc on va vous entendre oui je pense
avez vous des regrets est ce que des
fois vous dites oui je veux aller trop
loin je vais aller trop vite sur le
plateau j'ai peut-être voulu jeu
peut-être marcher sur des orteils des
citoyens qui en toute bonne foi était
contre vos projets que vous invite à ses
avez vous avez vous avez vous des
regrets sur la façon dont j'avais fais
de la politique je dois vous avouer que
non ça sera le fameux dire oui je lâche
paraît très bien mais maintenant c'est
effectivement il ya déjà des victimes
collatérales
c'est à dire que quand on renverse une
rue de sens s'il y avait un commerçant
qui avait un commerce où tout le monde à
gré par cette porte là que tout le monde
quand tu pensais tu vas y arrêtaient
proches qui leur fait à cet endroit là
c'est une victime collatérale mais elle
existe bien là elle existe un non-lieu
no mercy dur pour les commercialiser
rencontre quand je rencontre un certain
de ces personnes-là des résidents ou des
commerçants ou des familles en fait une
seule fois où j'ai réussi à faire
abandonner un stationnement que les
personnes aient un droit acquis pour
construire un stationnement on voulait
faire une ruelle vert puis l'abandonné
stable une seule fois un couple une
seule fois le reste du temps c'était des
conflits d'intérêts c'était deux pas des
conflits d'intérêts c'est un conflit
entre des personnes qui avaient des
intérêts et je suis conscient que ça
fait mal à certaines personnes
allez vous vous représentez allez-vous
essayer de reformer un groupe plus vert
pour montréal non la politique s'est
terminée par trois sets à mener pour
l'instant
si j'avais voulu chercher indépendant en
restant indépendant j'aurais pu attirer
des insatisfaits j'aurais pu donner
contre la mairesse a à chaque moment et
en faisant ça je fragilisé projet
montréal puis on est dans un contexte où
il n'y a presque pas de partis
progressistes là au canada qui on se
dirige vers une administration pétards
et cris de l'asrock pas du tout au parti
conservateur
je veux pas que projet montréal soit
divisée par ma présence en tant
qu'indépendant et je les gens continuent
à les soutenir
c'était ma prochaine question et d'une
campagne électorale fédérale candidat
pour le parti vert pour le npd pour les
libéraux c'est dans les villes que ça se
passe c'est ça c'est non c'est non c'est
dans les villes que ça se passe il faut
acquérir les dirigeants na li oui mais
c'est je faire je m'en vais en étant
conscients qu'ils aient assez de monde
qui va faire pression sur le cabinet sur
la mairesse pour que ça se passe à
montréal
très bien l'anglais avez vous un emploi
ce qu'il ya eu une offre plus rapidement
la trajectoire
non par contre faut que je me trouve un
parce que en partant entre deux entre
demanda donc je suis pris vie des
locations départ ou de transition alors
je me trouvais un nombre qui vous n'avez
pas d'allocation de 10 par an
non parce que c'est la nouvelle
réglementation lorsqu'on quitte entre
demandant de rien même pas tous majeurs
à mon sentiment d'urgence pour vos
boucles et avec ça était telle que vous
ai dit c'est maintenant j'en peux plus
là mais mon sentiment d'urgence c'est
que moi je regarde mon fils le puis je
me dis lui c'est la première génération
qu'europe pas le droit de procréer c'est
un sentiment assez urgent pour que je
fasse ce genre d'édition gillot chose
lorsqu'on y aura peut-être pas envie de
croquer voilà il va avoir des
contraintes à la procréation pour la
première fois la plus grande joie d'un
humain on voit là on va là privé à nous
et à nos petits enfants
luc ferrandez en tout cas vous avez
toujours accepté les entrevues je le
souligne même quand ça n'allait pas bien
bien des fois que ça allait
effectivement pas bien
donc même après des gars vous avez
toujours été là je vous salue pour ça
puis bonne chance pour la suite puis ça
a été quand même tout un coup de
tonnerre allons aussi tard avant les
bulletins de nouvelles c'est très bien
ça nous fait patiner plus vite merci à
la prochaine sur ouagadougou